we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P here
is a just vicious, vicious attack on the David
Pakman show from a Trump supporter.
Take a listen.
Yeah.
Well, mr Pacman, I'm not Donald Trump, so
maybe what you need to do is stick your tail
between your leg and cower down and sneak
off like your dog.
Got that like a dog and a little weasel.
Thank you.
Bye.
That's right.
I don't know how the program will ever survive
that, so we won't even attempt to fight back
against this type of, uh, of, of just, um,
you know, brilliant and devastating political
critique.
Jeff sessions is announcing a run for Senate.
We're going to discuss that on today's bonus
show.
Italy is going to become the first country
to make learning about climate change compulsory
for school students and LA Las Vegas continues
to criminalize poverty and homelessness, adopting
a new ban, which prohibits sleeping, camping
on streets and sidewalks.
Um, we, there's actually a lot to say about
this and as someone who goes to Vegas twice
a year, um, I have some thoughts about it.
So we will be discussing that in detail on
today's bonus show.
What is the bonus or the bonus show is another,
it's an additional show that we do every day.
We've got the broadcast show, which we are
rapidly approaching the conclusion of for
today.
And then we've got the bonus show.
If you want to access the bonus show, become
a member@joinpacmandotcomorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
Tom slash David Pakman show at at least the
$5 a month level, and that will get you instant
access to the bonus show.
I will speak to you then the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.